and it carries out of bounds and here is
i'm sure this is going to be a surprise
to those
on hand as he hears it from this crowd
18-year veteran out of florida
[Applause]
he has been the guy
in the locker room as pat riley
among those applauding udata's haslam
such an important player even though he
has not
been on the court very much but he has
been
so important in terms of the culture of
this team over the years
well case in point did you just see him
almost come up with that
steel and loose ball right there at age
40. it is what it is down here along
with
dwyane wade and alonzo mourning i mean
these guys were just straight
up tough and haslam is one of those guys
three-time champion
he understands winning
[Music]
there are three championship batters
up above
there's the architect right there pat
riley
think about the success that he has had
throughout his basketball life
coming off of a big game the other night
that's his first bucket
and a foul is called on on haslam
and now haslam's having words with
dwight howard
i'm loving this right now oh here we go
muslim
pointing the finger may have made
contact
he talked about his toughness before
rajiv there is a certain
sense of urgency to this game for both
teams
although miami has jumped in front with
red hot shooting
this is great because these two teams
potentially could see one another
in the second round see first of all he
howard throws them to the ground here on
this uh
as they they got tangled up for our
rebound
now here's the words between haslam
and there's the point may have been
contact yeah
yep he's gone they they ejected him
so udonis his only appearance of this
regular season plays a
a couple of minutes hits two shots it
was effective
yes it was mate you buckets as well as
picked up that offensive foul on maxie
let's see you know what this is another
thing that is going to
rile up this miami heat team don't you
think jimmy butler and trevor ariza who
was getting into it earlier
with joelle embiid they're trying to
plant a seed marv you know this
they are trying to plant a seed
meanwhile the technical foul missed by
shake
milton you can see after dwight howard
has
shoved adonis haslam haslam for a moment
sitting on the floor thinking now
what should i how should i respond
he was trying to control himself and
then he got up and
there was this point in the push marv if
you saw what
[Music]
he's having he's kind of having
conversations with doc about what's
going on
he was the peacemaker when trevor ariza
was trying to go after joel embiid
if you remember that earlier in the
first quarter it was haslem who was the
peacemaker
now he's right in the middle of it and
i'm